- [Kelly Clarkson] Have a
seat. You look gorgeous.
- Thank you. So do you.
- Oh, it's nice to see you.
We were just both like a
month ago at the Emmys.
- I know. I was so happy to see you there.
I was like, there's my girl up there.
- Did you have fun at it?
'Cause I wasn't sitting at it.
- I had so much fun.
- I had to come in and out.
I was doing another job
so I came in and out-
- Of course you were.
- I was jealous that y'all got to eat.
I was like, wait, what?
- Well, that was a first.
The Emmys this year was really different
because in the past it's always just been
you sit in the audience
and you watch the show.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Oh, I'd never been.
- Yeah, you sit in the
audience, you watch the show
and there's no food,
there's not even any water.
And by the end you're like,
(groans) glamor is so hard.
So this year they put
tables around the stage.
There were tables all over
the place and there was wine
on the tables.
We were like, yeah, it's a party now.
But it was pretty funny because our table,
we were like front and
center, but behind the stage.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Oh, you
were behind the walk thing.
- Were behind the like, walkway stage.
And so everything that was happening
on the stage was pointed away from us.
So we had amazing views
of everybody's butts.
(audience laughs)
I mean, I'll tell you-
- You're welcome.
- Anything you wanna know
about anybody's butts.
So I got to see you present.
- You're welcome.
- I got to see your cute,
cute, cute, cute butt.
And it was really one of
the best of the nights.
(Kelly laughs)
So I wanna say congratulations to you.
- I wanted to say like, it was so cool,
I'd never been to the Emmys.
So I walked out and I was like, wait,
they get like food and drink at this one?
I was like-
- It was totally new.
- Why is this my first time?
- It's never happened before.
- I didn't know.
It was so fun.
Did you get to meet anyone
or talk to anyone that you really were-
- Oh my gosh, I had so much fun.
Yeah, you know, that's just
such an incredible experience
'cause you see all the
people who have been
your inspiration your whole life.
But that night I got
to meet Henry Winkler.
- I love him.
- I was doing an interview
and it was right next to him,
and I was supposed to be behaving myself
and paying attention and
talking to the person.
But I couldn't help it.
I was like, ah!
And I just started freaking
out over Henry Winkler because,
and luckily he is the
kindest man on the planet.
But I said to him, I said,
you know, he was The Fonz.
- [Kelly Clarkson] I get it.
- The Fonz! Fonzie. "Happy Days."
Those were the shows,
I grew up at that time when there were all
these great sitcoms on,
those were the shows
that really inspired me
and made me wanna be an actress.
And he was, you know,
the coolest of the cool.
And the thing that I told him, I said,
"You inspired me so
much at such a young age
to want to do this,
but now you continue to
inspire me because you are
so graceful and so humble and
so kind and so enthusiastic."
- Somebody to model ourselves after.
- He's been doing this
his whole entire life.
Years and years and years and years.
And it seems every time you see him speak,
he is just as thrilled that
he woke up that morning
and got to go to work as he
probably was 50 years ago.
And I just think he's great.
- He is, and I love that you're doing that
'cause we always hear
bad stuff about people.
But he is legit the
nicest on and off camera.
And I actually first met him
when I was like 19 years old
here in LA before anything.
And I did something and
he was directing it and
he was so nice to like,
we were extras like,
you know what I'm saying?
Like he didn't have to be.
And he was so nice to everyone and like,
treated everyone equally.
And it was like, really cool to see that.
- I mean that's just, you know,
you want that in this business.
You want it in the world, period.
And people feel that
and that's just really-
- [Kelly Clarkson] And that's
why he's still killing it.
- Yeah.
- So you're co-star from
"White Lotus," Sydney Sweeney,
she was here and she was fanning over you,
just saying how incredible that you were.
And you've become like one
of her biggest fans, right?
- Well, she is, I just
find her so impressive.
You know, we met for the first time when
we were doing "White Lotus."
She was playing my daughter.
I can't believe it that
now I have a series
of these incredible young women
who have been my daughters.
I feel like now I have
all these TV daughters.
But Sydney, there's something about her.
She's so incredibly talented and
becoming so incredibly successful.
I mean she's just really
like, honed into who she is.
And I really admire that
at such a young age to
be able to tap into that but
also stay really grounded.
She's super close with her family.
She, you know-
- It's hard to do in this industry.
- It really is.
So yeah. I really admire her.
- I love this about this story.
I think my favorite part
is just the supporting
of other women.
Like, how important do you think that is?
'Cause I feel like we always
get pitted against each other.
And it's not fair
to other women and to society
in general, but also to us,
'cause it's like, no
one's thinking that way.
- Well, you know, it's funny that you,
I mean, that to me has been
one of the most important parts
of my career really,
just really of my life.
Because no matter what I,
if I was, you know, a
teacher in a public school,
I would still be wanting
to do the exact same thing,
and that is to support my fellow humans,
but particularly my fellow women and like,
lift each other up.
And you know, it's funny
talking about the Emmys
the other night because in my
category there were five of us
from my show, the "White Lotus,"
that were nominated in my category.
- I mean, congratulations being a part
of such a killer cast.
That's what I'm saying. That's so amazing-
- Well no, it's an
amazing cast. Thank you.
- That's an honor that you're
with all these people
that are, that's cool.
- It was so cool.
I've never had an experience like that.
And everybody was like, "Oh, you know,
are you feeling competitive?"
And I thought, oh my gosh.
I could not feel more thrilled
that I get to be there
with my fellow actresses.
Like, look at you being lifted up,
like my fellow actresses in the category.
- And a select few.
- We can like do that for each other
and acknowledge each other.
And by the way, I'm inspired
by each and every one of them.
So it's just to me like, boy,
if we can hold each other
and support each other
in a world that wants to tear
us down, that's the goal.
- But also, maybe that's why you all
were nominated together,
because when you do have a cast that
is supportive like that
and you all actually
do wanna lift each other up,
the project becomes even better.
The chemistry becomes magical.
- I think so.
And you know, that show in particular,
we shot it during COVID.
It was like really like the beginning of
the scary part of COVID.
We were in a real bubble.
So we really, we had that camaraderie,
and I think that was really special.
- We are back with Connie Britton, y'all.
(audience clapping)
That was a look at her new Netflix movie,
"Luckiest Girl Alive."
So can you tell us about
the movie and who you play?
- Well, "Luckiest Girl
Alive," you know, I'm not,
I can't, (chuckles) I
can't tell you too much.
(Kelly laughs)
I've been sworn to secrecy, so.
But you know there is,
there's a lot in the movie that happens
that deals with some pretty
heavy subject matter.
- Yeah.
- And, but I play,
again, I'm in sort of a
mother-daughter relationship
with Mila Kunis's character.
And you know, it felt
really important to me.
I love storytelling as a
way to help people grow
and learn in the culture.
- Perspective.
- And you know,
the movie deals with some things
that are really pretty traumatic
and culturally important for us to look at
and understand why these
things are happening
in our culture, you know,
various forms of violence in our culture.
And so I really wanted to do it
because I play Mila Kunis's mom.
And in doing that,
it helps when I show that,
when we show that relationship
it helps remind us that we all have trauma
and we pass it down from generation
to generation to generation.
And when we keep just
passing down the trauma
instead of stopping to understand
that we need to change
that trauma and we need
to change the cycle of violence,
then nothing's gonna change.
And so, I really hope that the
movie is gonna be impactful
for people in terms of
just having a glimpse at,
"Oh, if I can stop the cycle
of hurt in my own family
or in my own community,
that can make a difference going forward."
- Yeah, you just reminded me of something
that Jesse actually told me one time.
I don't know know where she
got it, a friend or something.
But it was, if you change,
'cause I was having a hard
time and it's very hard,
generational trauma or trauma
that you're going through.
But if you could change one thing,
if you could just change
one thing that you're doing
that you feel like is
negative or not helpful,
then the whole circle widens and changes.
And I think that that's so important,
like what you're talking
about in the show.
So I think these stories
truly make a big impact
and can be quite triggering
for a lot of people with
that generational trauma.
Is that really important to you
to do those kind of stories?
- I do think it's important,
but I think you also
have to do it in a way
that's compassionate
because trauma is a hard thing to look at.
And so I think that's
why in the world of film
and television and the art world,
we can find ways to make it accessible
and to make it okay to look.
- And a learning thing.
- And learn, yeah.
Exactly.
- I agree.
Well, what are the most important things
that you're trying to
teach your son right now?
- Well, my son is 11 now and you know,
he's really, it's kind of
the beginning of growing,
I can see him growing into a little man.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Oh, that freaks me out.
- Right?
- My son is six. I'm sweating.
- Oh, he's only six.
- Yeah.
- Oh gosh.
- I don't want him to grow up! (laughs)
- I know.
It's really interesting because I just,
I respect him so much.
Like, I love the little
man that he's becoming
and his thoughtfulness
and sort of observation
of the world and I really want to like,
let that live for him.
But, you know, I also
realize as he gets older
he's gonna be coming into a world that
has very strong expectations for him.
I have very strong
expectations for him in terms
of respecting everybody around
him and just who he has to be
in the world.
And you know, it's especially,
you know, my son is a young black boy
and as he gets older,
the culture is gonna look
at him differently.
- Is that hard to teach?
- It's a real learning
curve for me to teach him.
- But it's important.
- I know it's my responsibility.
So I start with,
I just wanna give him an
environment that has the most love
and the most security
because I know that that will fill him up.
- That foundation.
- And give him a foundation so
that then hopefully it can
help protect him when he's
out in the world and give him
respect and accountability.
And you know, it's scary
though 'cause they're kids.
He's an 11 year old kid.
He doesn't know anything and
all they do is make mistakes
and all they do is screw up.
And half the time they don't
even know what they've done.
And so it's, you know,
I'm starting to be like,
- It's hard, those big issues.
- You wanna try to anticipate
what they're gonna be facing
and that's just one of the
tricky parts of being a mom.
- It's like anticipating, yeah.
It's the balance of
anticipating but also going,
I don't wanna rip that innocence from you
quite yet, you know?
It's hard.
- That's right.
I want him to be able to make mistakes.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- That's important. We have
to be able to make mistakes.
It's part of our learning and growing.
So it's really that balance.
Oh, being a mama, it's all that balance.
- Oh yeah. I talk about
it regularly in therapy.
So how do you help him
process what he sees going on
in the world?
'Cause there are some big,
huge, major issues going on.
I was asked, we just a while
back went to Uvalde, Texas,
my home state.
And just, I was asked by
one of the people involved
in the organization, like,
"Have you talked to your kids about this?"
And I'm like, oh. I'm like,
that's a hard conversation.
Like how do you not terrify them,
but ready them and prepare them?
Like, it's a really
hard thing to navigate.
- I know. It's so hard.
- It's a very difficult thing.
And you said having a young black boy
and you're a white mother,
that's a whole other thing of issues.
So yeah. How do you do that?
How do you do those big-
- It's really-
- Do you have a group of
people, like friends or?
- I do, but you know, I find
everybody does it differently.
And you know, I'm a single
mom and he's an only child
and so we have like a really
special, close relationship.
And I try to let him,
I try to let him find the space to,
as these things are coming up
and we are having the conversation,
I try to like gauge where
he is with it, you know?
And honestly he's, now that he's 11,
he's starting to have
awareness of these things.
The other day, it was so cute, you know,
the queen had just passed
away and he, (chuckles)
we hadn't talked about it.
And he came, we were getting
ready for school and he said,
"Mom, did you hear about the queen?"
I was like, "Oh, I know, I know.
She was queen for so, so, so long."
He goes, "It's just so sad." (laughs)
- Like to see your little man,
like have a conversation
like that is so crazy.
- And it was so cute
because I thought he has no connection
to the queen whatsoever.
- But to show empathy.
- He had no idea that she
was queen for so many decades.
- But that little like sliver of empathy,
you know what I'm saying?
That's nice.
- And so I think getting back
to your point, it's like it is
about the empathy and it's
about gauging where they are
with their own empathy and
with their own ability to
handle the big topics, you know?
- I let mine come to me mostly.
- Me too.
- Yeah, 'cause I'm like, you know what,
all kids are different, and
both my kids are so different.
Those conversations are far apart.
They're very different developmentally.
So I let them come to me
and I hope that's the right decision
but if not, well,
we all gotta be in
therapy for something, so.
- (laughs) Well, we're screwing it up.
- [Kelly Clarkson] That's your thing.